i'm an engineer by my undergraduate
education and an engineer by my
postgraduate education as well one thing
led to the other and commercial real
estate popped up i was appointed as the
global chief information officer
in early march of 2020 i have to say
that my leadership through this journey
of the company and the people in the
company have benefited greatly from my
experience at sap the connection points
that one would build from the program
and how long
lasting that would be and how that would
transpire into
meaningful things that you know either
clusters of us
or all of us would do the 2019 scp group
had got together and talked about
building a fund that would help
entrepreneurs with
much needed capital in areas that we
thought we believed in as a collective
group i am very proud to say that that
idea has transformed into a company our
focus is really around
investments that conform to
the principles of the stanford slogan
change lives change organizations change
the world
[Music]